si empezamos con un ácido carboxílicos y
le agregamos amoniaco podrías pensar que
el amoniaco funcionará como un núcleo
filo podrías pensar que atacará justo
aquí perderás tu voz y formarás una
amiga como tu producto sin embargo esto
no es lo que sucede a temperatura
ambiente el amoniaco funcionará como una
base y tomará el protón nacido en tu
ácidos carboxílicos
dejando a estos electrones atrás en tu
oxígeno de hecho formarás tu añón
carboxilasa aquí
tres pares libres en tu exige no
dándole una carga formal de menos 1 se
añade es un protón al amoniaco
formarás amonio cierto nh4 más y
entonces tenemos nuestra sal de amonio
aquí si calientas esta sal puedes formar
en algunas ocasiones tu amiga sin
embargo ésta definitivamente no es la
mejor manera de hacer una amiga una
mejor manera sería utilizar algo llamado
de cc hagamos un poco más de espacio
aquí abajo para poder ver cómo se ve el
de cc
es un acrónimo para biciclo exile carbó
dignidad tenemos la b la c y la cea aquí
así que si este grupo ere doble prima es
un grupo ciclo xxi lo tendríamos dcc si
empiezas con tu ácidos carboxílicos y
agregas una mina el uso de veces se
permite a tu amina funcionar como núcleo
filo y eventualmente formar tu amiga
como tu producto así que veamos el
mecanismo el primer paso es que el dsc
funcione como una base entonces este par
libre de electrones en el nitrógeno toma
este protón dejando estos electrones
atrás en tu oxígeno hagamos un poco más
de espacio aquí
vamos a continuar quitando un protón de
tu ácidos carboxílicos
lo cual te da un año
carboxilasa así que continuamos
dibujando nuestro cañón car box y la pto
tres pares libres de electrones en
nuestro oxígeno una carga formal de
menos 1
estén hidrógeno tomará ese protón por lo
que el nitrógeno ahora tiene una carga
formal de más 1 así que mostramos
algunos electrones estos electrones en
magenta tomarán este protón formando
este enlace después de tomar este protón
y podemos pensar en estos electrones
moviéndose a nuestro oxígeno para formar
nuestro año un kart box y la pto
dibujemos el resto de esto tenemos un
nitrógeno
doblemente unido a un carbono el cual
está unido a otro litro geno con un par
libre de electrones y tenemos nuestro
grupo r doble prima ya que acabamos de
protón ar este nitrógeno realmente
quiere electrones puede quitar algo de
densidad electrónica de este carbono y
entonces este carbono va a perder algo
de densidad electrónica y se volverá un
poco positivo y entonces ahora este
carbono es electro físico y nuestro año
carboxilasa funcionará como núcleo filo
en nuestro siguiente paso el núcleo filo
ataca nuestro electro filo
empujando a estos electrones
nitrógeno
continuemos mostrando eso ahora tenemos
nuestro carbono doblemente unido a este
oxígeno
y ahora este oxígeno aquí abajo ha
formado un enlace con este carbono
esos electrones en azul ha formado este
enlace ahora y este carbono está
enlazado a este nitrógeno enlazado a
este hidrógeno y al grupo r doble prima
y si mostramos hagamos a estos
electrones verdes estos electrones
verdes se movieron a nuestro nitrógeno
así y entonces nuestro carbono también
está enlazado está doblemente enlazado a
este nitrógeno enlazado a nuestro grupo
r doble prima
bien en el siguiente paso nuestra amena
funcionará como núcleo filo así que
continuamos dibujando nuestra mina
tenemos nuestro
hidrógeno con dos hidrógenos
y un grupo r prima un par libre de
electrones en nuestro nitrógeno permite
a esta mina funcionar como núcleo fino
continuamos poniendo esos electrones en
magenta aquí este oxígeno es
parcialmente negativo va a quitar algo
de densidad electrónica de este carbono
dejándolo parcialmente positivo y
entonces tenemos un núcleo filo que va a
atacar nuestro electro filo nuestra mina
atacará a este carbono mandando a esos
electrones al oxígeno entonces
continuamos mostrando el resultado de
este ataque núcleo físico bien hagamos
un poco de espacio aquí abajo tenemos a
nuestro carbono enlazado a este oxígeno
así que continuamos dibujando esos
electrones una carga formal de menos 1
en este oxígeno
si estos electrones en verde se mueven a
nuestro oxígeno obtienen una carga
formal de menos solo este carbono está
enlazado a un grupo r también está
enlazado a este nitrógeno
este nitrógeno
ahora tiene una carga formal de más 1
una carga formal de más uno en nuestro
nitrógeno
después de que los electrones en magenta
se movieron acá para formar este enlace
bien aún tenemos a este carbono unido a
este oxígeno y dibujamos estos pares
libres de electrones y luego tenemos
este carbono tenemos nuestro hidrógeno
tenemos nuestro grupo r doble prima
tenemos un hidrógeno un par libre de
electrones un doble enlace con este
nitrógeno por aquí con nuestro grupo r
doble prima bien hay muchas cosas
sucediendo aquí el uso de dcc te deja un
buen grupo saliente si pensamos en todo
esto
este es un excelente grupo saliente si
volvemos a formar nuestro carbón y lo
continuamos mostrando eso si estos
electrones de aquí se mueven acá para
formar nuestro carbón y lo estos
electrones pueden irse al oxígeno
e incluso mostrar el movimiento hasta
acá para ahorrar algo de tiempo y si hay
un protón aquí afuera estos electrones
pueden tomar ese protón tenemos un
excelente grupo saliente tenemos de
hecho biciclo exile urea por aquí a la
derecha si círculo todo esto
obtendremos
biciclo exile urea y continuamos
mostrando lo que pasaría si formamos
nuevamente nuestro carbón y lo usemos
estos electrones en rojo estos
electrones en rojo se mueven ahora
tenemos un grupo r un carbono ahora está
doblemente enlazado al oxígeno con solo
dos pares libres de electrones los
electrones en rojo se movieron para
formar nuevamente nuestro carbón hilo y
luego y luego este carbono aún está
enlazado a este nitrógeno por lo que
continuamos dibujando a este nitrógeno
aquí y si pensamos en una base tomando a
este protón déjame cambiar colores una
base tomando este protón dejando estos
electrones atrás estos electrones se
quedarán atrás
en este nitrógeno los dibujaré aquí en
azul y ahora sólo tenemos un hidrógeno
en este nitrógeno y luego tenemos
nuestro grupo r prima así
más de ciclo exile urea como nuestro
otro producto hemos formado nuestra
amiga otra vez de ese se permite a la
mina funcionar como núcleo filo bien
veamos algunos de los usos conocidos del
dcc uno de los usos más conocidos para
el dsc es reaccionar aminoácidos juntos
para formar para formar péptidos así que
si tenemos un aminoácido aquí en la
izquierda con un grupo r al cual
llamaremos r1 y tenemos un aminoácido
aquí en la derecha con un grupo r
diferente tenemos r2 no nos
preocuparemos por la estéreo química
aquí podríamos juntar estos aminoácidos
usando dcc si observamos al ácido
carboxílicos de la izquierda y nuestra
amina aquí a la derecha
sabemos que el dsc puede formar una
amiga ahora para algo así debes de ser
un poco más cuidadoso porque tienes una
amina de este lado y un ácido
carboxílicos en este lado
y entonces tienes que añadir un grupo
protector
así que continuamos pensando en un grupo
protector que esté de este lado y
podríamos cambiar esto a un grupo
protector
algo como oh r prima un esther en lugar
de un ácido carboxílicos y añadimos
desde c podemos pensar en ds como
nuestro agente de deshidratación podemos
pensar en perder agua continuamos
mostrando eso perdemos el h de nuestro
ácidos carboxílicos y la h de nuestra
amina podemos ver que eso es h2o si
pensamos en menos
h2o podemos juntar esos dos aminoácidos
continuamos haciendo eso tendríamos
nuestro carbón y lo
enlazado a un nitrógeno
enlazado a un hidrógeno aquí y luego
tendremos nuestro grupo r y luego
tenemos nuestro ácidos carboxílicos
continuaré poniendo a r prima aquí por
lo que nuestro ácidos carboxílicos fue
protegido en este lado para formar un
externa por aquí tendremos nuestro grupo
r 1
tenemos nuestro nitrógeno
nuestro hidrógeno y dependiendo de qué
grupo protector estés usando solo
continuaré poniendo esto así
formamos un de péptido por aquí puedes
ver nuestra habilidad
y aquí está nuestro enlace peptídicos
que se formó
esto fue desarrollado en los años 50s en
el límite y fue publicado por el grupo
del doctor sheehan alrededor del año
1955 y de hecho llama a esto que dice
quitar el h y la h y pensar en
removerlos para perder agua como química
lazo ciertamente no es la mejor manera
de pensar en lo que está pasando
exactamente
pero es una buena manera de pensar en
juntar a estos dos aminoácidos
individuales para formar tu disc péptido
y el grupo del doctor sheehan están
usando dcc en los 50s y por supuesto se
convirtió en lo estándar para formar
péptidos y por supuesto hay versiones
diferentes de eso ahora pero esto fue un
descubrimiento en los 50s y el doctor
sheehan también estaba involucrado en la
síntesis total de la penicilina en los
50s y cuando uso de cc como agente de
acoplamiento para formar sus péptidos en
su laboratorio pensó que también podría
usarlo para formar penicilina veamos la
estructura de la penicilina
aquí en la derecha está la sal de
penicilina y esta de hecho es de la
síntesis total de penicilina del doctor
sigan él fue el primero en hacerlo en
1957 si vemos por aquí podemos ver una
lámina y podemos ver un ácido
carboxílicos y si hacemos nuestra
química lazo si tomamos este o h y está
h y pensamos en perder agua y puedes ver
que aquí tenemos una amiga en nuestro
anillo una vida en un anillo es llamada
una la cama ésta es muy famosa esta es
una vez
luck
más
la perdiz y lina es un antibiótico beta
lactamasa es llamada beta lactamasa
porque el carbono junto a tu carbón y lo
aquí sería tu carbono alfa y el carbono
de juntos sería tu carbono o beta aquí
tenemos un anillo de 4 miembros para
formar nuestra beta lactamasa el doctor
sheehan utilizó de cese en su síntesis
para unir esto y esta beta lactamasa era
extremadamente difícil de hacer para
otros químicos
durante la segunda guerra mundial había
varios laboratorios trabajando en esto
creo que el doctor sheehan escribió en
su libro su libro es llamado el anillo
encantado o enchanted ring en inglés
porque hacer este anillo beta lactamasa
era extremadamente difícil ésta era la
parte difícil cómo formar un anillo beta
lactamasa era extremadamente difícil
para la mayoría de los químicos hacerlo
pero el uso de dcc el cual puede usarse
puedes hacerlo en agua puedes hacerlo a
temperatura ambiente puedes hacerlo en
condiciones de reacción relativamente
normales eso hizo que él fuera la
primera persona en sintetizar penicilina
la primera síntesis total de penicilina
de acuerdo a lo que dice en su libro no
había competencia en aquel tiempo y
pensaba que los químicos los otros
químicos simplemente estaban hartos de
intentarlo es química bastante
interesante
y hablaré más de la penicilina en un
vídeo posterior